BE VERY EASY TO ACHIEVE IN A
REASONABLE TIME.
BRET.
>> Bret: RICH EDSON AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ALL THESE
FOREIGN POLICY CHALLENGES WITH
BRIAN HOOK, SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT FROM
WASHINGTON.
BRIAN, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Bret: LET'S START WITH IRAN
AND WHAT SECRETARY POMPEO SAID
TODAY.
HOW REALISTIC DOES THIS      SEC
HOW REALISTIC DOES THIS      SEE
HOW REALISTIC DOES THIS      SEA
HOW REALISTIC DOES THIS      SEY
HOW REALISTIC DOES THIS      SE,
STATE DEPARTMENT, ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVE THAT THESE 12
STIPULATIONS WILL ACTUALLY BE
AGREED TO EVENTUALLY BUY IRAN.
>> >> IS A OF REQUIREMENTS THAT
SECRETARY POMPEO CALLED OUT
TODAY IN HIS SPEECH IN IRAN IS A
VERY REASONABLE AND REALISTIC
LIST.
IT COULD GO THROUGH THE LIST,
FOCUSING ON IRAN'S NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PROGRAM.
SUPPORT FOR TERRORISM.
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS       W
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS       R
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS       T
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS       F
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS       N
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS       S
IT'S FOREIGN WARRANTLESS       .
ALL OF THESE ARE POSITIONS THAT
EUROPEAN ALLIES HAVE HELD AT ONE
TIME OR ANOTHER.
THIS IS THE KIND OF NEW APPROACH
THAT WE ARE TAKING TO CREATE A
NEW SECURITY ARCHITECTURE IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE TOTALITY OF
IRAN'S THREATS.
>> Bret: HERE IS SOMEONE WHO
NEGOTIATED BEFORE.
FORMER AMBASSADOR WENDY SHERMAN.
>> I THINK POMPEO GAVE US A WISH
LIST TODAY AND IT'S A WISH LIST
PROBABLY EVERYBODY COULD AGREE
TO.
YOU CAN GET IT ALL AT ONCE
BECAUSE THEN YOU ARE NEGOTIATING
AGAINST YOURSELF, AS ONE IS
TRADED OFF AGAINST THE OTHER.
>> Bret: YOUR RESPONSE.
>> I THINK THAT'S A VERY
DEFEATIST ATTITUDE, AND I THINK
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO ADDRESSING
THE FULL RANGE OF IRANIAN
THREATS, WE DO NEED TO TAKE A
COPPERHEADS OF THEM VERY
AMBITIOUS APPROACH.
THE SPEECH THAT SECRETARY POMPEO
DELIVERED TODAY DOES EXACTLY
THAT.
>> Bret: YEAH, ON THE TWEETS
COMING FROM THE IRANIANS, AT THE
END OF IT, AND REFERENCES THAT
IRAN IS STILL WORKING WITH
EUROPEAN PARTNERS TO CONTINUE
THE JCPOA, THE IRAN NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT THAT THE U.S. PULLED
OUT OF.
HOW MUCH LOVE OUR PROBLEM IS
THAT GOING FORWARD AND HOW YOU
CALCULATE THAT?
>> I THINK THE UNITED STATES AND
ITS EUROPEAN ALLIES SHARE A VERY
SIMILAR THREAT ASSESSMENT, AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS TO
ADDRESS THE DEFICIENCIES OF THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
WE ALSO MADE PROGRESS ON ALL OF
THE MALIGNED ACTIVITIES THAT
FALL OUTSIDE OF THE NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THAT
FOUNDATIONAL WORK CAN BE BUILT
UPON.
BUT WE ARE NOT JUST LIMITING OUR
WORK TO THE EUROPEAN ALLIES.
SECRETARY POMPEO HAS INVITED
NATIONS FROM AROUND THE WORLD
THAT SHARE HIS CONCERNS TO JOIN
US IN THIS DIPLOMATIC EFFORT.
WE ARE LOOKING TO WORK WITH
NATIONS WHO ARE SICK AND TIRED
OF IRAN'S QUEST FOR A NUCLEAR
WEAPON, WHO ARE TIRED OF IRAN'S
TERRORISM, FOR ITS FUNDING AND
FUELING SECTARIAN VIOLENCE, FOR
VIOLATING HUMAN RIGHTS.
WE HAVE SET FORTH A VERY
AMBITIOUS AGENDA THAT WE THINK
MUCH OF THE WORLD CAN GET
BEHIND.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TOUCH ON
TWO OTHER QUICK THINGS.
FINALLY ON IRAN, WHAT DO YOU SAY
TO CRITICS WHO LOOK AT THIS AND
SAY IT'S NOT ABOUT ANOTHER DEAL.
IT'S ABOUT REGIME CHANGE OR THE
POSSIBILITY OF REGIME CHANGE.
>> THE ONLY THING WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IS A CHANGE IN THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE IRANIAN REGIME.
NOT JUST THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S THE IRANIAN PEOPLE.
THE LONGEST SEVERING VICTIMS OF
THE IRANIAN REGIME OR THE
IRANIAN PEOPLE AND THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR A BETTER LIFE IN A
BETTER FUTURE.
THEY'VE HAD PROTESTS WHERE
THEY'VE EXPRESSED THIS.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE BETTER
ECONOMICS.
THEY ARE TIRED OF THEIR
GOVERNMENT FUNDING FOREIGN WARS.
ROBBING FROM THE IRANIAN ECONOMY
TO SOW INSTABILITY ACROSS THE
MIDDLE EAST.
SO WE THINK WE HAVE SET FORTH
THE KIND OF POSITIVE VISION THAT
COULD ACTUALLY CHANGE RELATIONS
WITH IRAN.
THE SECRETARY PUT ON THE TABLE
THAT IF IRAN IS READY TO CHANGE
ITS BEHAVIOR, WE ARE READY TO
TALK ABOUT A RANGE OF BENEFITS,
INCLUDING FULL DIPLOMATIC TIES,
WELCOMING IRAN INTO THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY AND OTHER THINGS THAT
WOULD MATERIALLY IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THE IRANIAN PEOPLE.
>> Bret: IT'S A SIMILAR
NEGOTIATION WITH NORTH KOREA.
AS WE SIT HERE TODAY, WHEN DO
YOU THINK THE LIKELIHOOD IS THAT
THE JUNE 12 SUMMIT MOVES FORWARD
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
KIM JONG UN?
>> SECRETARY POMPEO HAS NOW MADE
TWO TRIPS TO NORTH KOREA TO TRY
TO SET THE TABLE FOR A
SUCCESSFUL MEETING IN SINGAPORE
ON JUNE 12.
THESE SORTS OF THINGS TAKE
TWISTS AND TURNS.
THAT'S NOT UNCOMMON WITH
NORTH KOREA.
SO ALL WE CAN DO IS TRY TO BE IN
A STATE OF READINESS AND TO DO
WHAT WE CAN SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A VERY GOOD DISCUSSION ABOUT, AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TALKED
ABOUT, VERY BRIGHT FUTURE FOR
THE NORTH KOREAN PEOPLE.
IF THE REGIME IS WILLING TO
DENUCLEARIZE.
>> Bret: LAST THING, FOR THE
PEOPLE ON CAPITOL HILL, PEOPLE
WHO ARE SKEPTICAL OF HOW THIS
HAS ALL COME TOGETHER, WHAT DO
YOU TELL THEM THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE PRESIDENT IS
NOT GOING TO GIVE THE STORE AWAY
OR IS NOT GOING TO GET PLAYED BY
EITHER NORTH KOREA OR CHINA IN
NEGOTIATIONS ONGOING.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
COMING IN FROM A POSITION OF
GREAT STRENGTH.
HE'S ASSEMBLED THE LARGEST
SANCTIONS CAMPAIGN AGAINST
NORTH KOREA IN HISTORY.
HE'S IN A VERY GOOD POSITION.
WHETHER DETOX HAPPEN OR NOT,
WHETHER THE TALKS GO WELL OR
POORLY, THE GLOBAL MAXIMUM
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN IS GOING
TO CONTINUE UNTIL WE ACHIEVE
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
OBJECTIVES.